ah c'est fini cette chasse à courre à
propos de chasse à courre il faut que je
vous raconte une histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
je vais voir on dirait de la musique
pour chiens
[Musique]
ou une espèce de boeuf c'est pas des
fins r1 ou le poster et qu'il allait
gentil cash et moi
les chiens sont sur ma tasse ils veulent
me manger aidez-moi autres et on va vous
cacher dans notre show ou et/ou par ici
par ici venez je vais mettre une
couverture portet et lors de ne pas y
avoir quoi
merci je n'oublierai jamais il
maintenant nyon l'air de rien je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on fait entrer un
boeuf dans la maison puisque je te dis
que c'est pas un homme c'est un tiers le
cerf est passé par ici
ou at il été qu'elle sert je sens une
odeur de serre allons à bout le tout à
l'heure vous avez vu arriver à cers dans
la cour vous en avez eu pitié et vous
l'avez fait rentrer dans la maison vous
assure
y a pas pire dans la maison je voudrais
bien comprendre
vous avez fait entrer une sorte de boeuf
dans la maison l'âme il prétend que
c'est un cerf mais même si c'est un cerf
je ne me vois pas pourquoi vous voulez
les belles feuilles de chou de didier
j'en étais sûr mon flair ne me trouble
fameck tron je disais que le cerf se
trouvait dans la maison c'était pour moi
comme si je le voyais baulon soyez
raisonnables et fait le sortir
songez que cette bête ne vous appartient
pas si mon maître apprenait ce qui s'est
passé il viendrait sûrement trouver vos
parents vous allez mieux depuis à voiron
ce n'est pas ma faute il faut bien que
j'obéis sammonds mais il ne faut pas
toujours à pays bas c'est drôle je ne
peux pas voir pleurer des petites
t'écouter je ne veux pas être méchant
après tout le cers ne m'a rien fait
tony je veux bien ne m aperçu de rien
merci tu es le meilleur des chiens mon
maître ne serait pas de votre avis mais
ne vous réjouissez pas j'entends aboyer
mes compagnons de meute
ils ont dû retrouver la trace du cerf et
vous n'allez pas tarder à les voir
apparaître alors que leur direz vous il
ne faut pas compter les attendre et
c'est alors que je décidé de prendre les
choses en main si j'ose dire bien
entendu je donnais aussitôt des ordres
aux deux petites
[Musique]
je me demande quel idéal un seau d'eau
fraîche et fleurs qui sont très forts je
le savais mais il fallait aller vite
je renvoyais les petites à leurs devoirs
et je me préparais à recevoir la meuse
et moi qu'est ce que je fais tu te
caches repêché mouton ou et les
responsabilités et dis moi ton nom pato
je réduis le devine même si vous venez
pour le sert il est passé par ici il ya
un quart d'heure veux te dire qu'il est
parmi nous oui il est entré dans la cour
et il en est ressorti aussitôt il y
avait déjà un chien sur sa trace un
chien pareil avoué qu'ils s'appellent
bateau à huy pas tous en f1 je vais vous
dire exactement la direction qu'a prises
le cerf inutile nous aurons bien
retrouver sa trace
permettez-moi auparavant de vous
féliciter je n'ai jamais vu d'aussi beau
chien que vous et je m'y connais en
chiens venant dans un chat le compliment
nous tous d'autant plus je dois
reconnaître on a toute modestie que nous
formons une bien belle meute où
j'aimerais vous offrir à boire avec tout
le travail que vous faites vous avez
besoin de vous rafraîchir ce n'est pas
de refus je voudrais aussi vous offrir
des fleurs pour vous récompenser d'être
si beau sujet bien aimable mais où veux
tu qu'on mette des fleurs il y a dans
cette ferme deux petites filles qui
savent faire des colliers de fleurs je
vais les appeler un marine est delphine
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi des colliers de fleurs pour que
leurs parts un cash longueur du cerf
nous vous remercions de votre accueil
tout le plaisir a été pour moi
et maintenant il nous faut rattraper
notre serre je vous en prie
1 c'est curieux d'où le sens en rien un
peu de rhume peut être non d'indiquer
nous la direction qu'a prises le serbe
volontiers il est parti d'abord vers les
temps puis il est entré dans la forêt à
l'endroit où elle fait une pointe sur la
campagne
merci il n'y a pas de quoi ils sont
partis vous voilà sauvés pour
aujourd'hui mais demain
pensez aux chiens aux chasseurs au fusil
un jour ou l'autre mon maître lancera à
nouveau la meute à votre poursuite
si vous étiez sage pour l'en seriez à
courir par les bois au coq et et les
bois je m'ennuierais trop et puis oui
c'est votre affaire
je pense en avoir assez fait pour vous a
lieu et le brave pathos en furent
rejoindre la meute bientôt suivi par le
cerf qui regagne à ses alliés non sans
nous avoir remercié les petites et moi
dieu merci pendant ces événements les
parents étaient absents
il s'était rendu à la foire du bourg
voisin pour acheter un boeuf ils
rentrèrent le soir mais de mauvaise
humeur il n'avait pas acheté de boeuf à
cause d'une épidémie de fièvre aphteuse
[Musique]
c'est malheureux avoir perdu toute une
journée pour ne rien trouver
avec quoi allons-nous travailler
maintenant n'est tout de même pas fallu
table bel attelage comme si un boeuf
pouvait suffire tu ferais mieux de te
taire on dirait qu'il s'est passé de
drôles de choses ici pendant notre
absence j'ai vu un show dans la cour
c'est moi qui ai fait voir le beau tout
à l'heure j'ai oublié de remettre le
saut en place
c'est bizarre
je parie qu'il va voir le jardin quand
il va s'apercevoir que toutes les
plantes ont été coupées toutes les
fleurs coupées
le jardin des valises et malheureuse on
va vous tirer les oreilles
arrêté par an ce ne sont pas elles qui
ont cueilli les fleurs en aurait-elle
fait mais à midi pendant qu'elle
déjeunait j'ai aperçu un vagabond qui
lorgnait le jardin depuis la route
je n'ai pas pris tellement garde mais
maintenant je suis sûr que c'est lui le
curé dû courir après lui vous me prenez
pour un chien je parvins à calmer les
parents au sujet de leurs fleurs
d'autant plus aisément que leurs grands
soucis ce jour là était de n'avoir pas
un second d'offres c'est alors que j'ai
eu une autre idée
ce ne sont pas les idées qui me manque
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
il utile de vous répéter ce que j'ai dit
auxerre vous l'avez certainement deviné
sachez seulement que je su le convaincre
et que le lendemain matin
bonjour je suis sincère je cherche du
travail
vous n'auriez pas quelques chose ici
pour moi oui d'abord savoir ce que tu
sais faire je sais courir trotter alejo
pas fait malgré mes jambes grêle je suis
fort ce que je peux porter de lourds
fardeaux
je peux aussi tirer une voiture seule ou
attelé en compagnie tout cela n'est pas
mal mais quels sont tes prétention audio
le logement la nourriture est bien
entendu que le repos du tibre on peut
faire un essai pièce c'est un compagnon
pour le boeuf
tâchez d'être convenable avec lui vous
avez là deux petites filles qui sont
bien jolies moi je suis sûr que je
m'entendrai très bien avec elle un
instant après le cerf avait rejoint le
boeuf à les tables et une heure après
ils étaient tous deux attelé à la
charrue
[Musique]
je trouve très amusant avec votre petit
arbre voir sur la tête
vos corps de ma muse également mais vous
semblez très gentil vous aussi
alors attention vous allez trop vite les
premières heures de travail furent
pénibles pour le cerf le difficile était
de régler son allure sur celle du boeuf
la charrue allé de travers car le cerf
n'aimait pas son travail tendue et je
crois qu'elle a mauvais esprit tu as
raison
qu'est ce que ça veut dire avoir mauvais
esprits se faire son travail sans
plaisir alors le serbe doit pas être
seul à voir mauvais esprit cependant
dans les tables lecerf parlait au boeuf
des bois des clairières des étangs sais
tu qu'il y a de lune une qui est au ciel
et l'autre dans l'eau les étangs pas
possible et si tu savais comme c'est bon
de galoper le matin travers les arbres
n'avoir pas de mettre ou pas
d'obligation pas d'heure mais courir à
sa fantaisie jouer avec les lapins
parler au coucou ou au sens du lisier je
ne dis pas mais les tables n'est pas
méprisable non plus la forêt je verrai
ça plutôt pour les vacances à la belle
saison en hiver ou par les grandes
pluies les bois ne sont guère agréable
mais au fond le boeuf songe est avec
envie à cette fit sous bois qu'il ne
connaîtrait jamais
il était surtout triste le dimanche
parce que ce jour-là le cerf allait
passer la journée dans les bois il avait
bien demandé la permission d'emmener le
boeuf
mais les parents avaient refusé
[Musique]
et delphine et marinette s'ennuyer à
mourir
elle était bien triste en l'absence du
cerf
[Musique]
on
où
les parents leur refusait toujours
l'autorisation de la compagnie
[Musique]
oh
ans
un dimanche après-midi seulement sous
prétexte d'aller cueillir du muguet est
le rejoignirent dans une clairière où
ils s'étaient donné rendez vous mais à
peine était-il ensemble bonjour oh
excusez moi je sens un chien n'ai pas
peur je suis pas tout en passant près
d'ici j'ai reconnu la voix des petites
et je suis venu vous dire bonjour à tous
alors qu'est-ce que tu es devenu je
travaille à la ferme
toi tu as bien raison et je te conseille
d'y rester toujours toujours ça n'est
pas possible si tu savais comme le
travail est ennuyeux et comme la plaine
est triste parce et grand soleil alors
qu'il fait si frais et si doux dans nos
bois les bois n'ont jamais été moins sûr
on chasse presque tous les jours hier
encore nous avons tué un vieux son
mythique qui avait une défense cassé
c'était mon meilleur ami à vous qui
l'avez tué au moins nous donc je
souhaitais avec les chiens fils ont
forcé il fallait bien mais quel métier
ainsi je pouvais moi aussi aller
travailler dans une ferme
j'estime ne pas avoir besoin d'un chien
à la mine
je ne peux pas contrôler un métier on
garde peu puis je ne voudrais pas
abandonner mes compagnons pour finir le
bras ce bateau voulu faire jurer auxerre
qu'il resterait à la ferme mais le cerf
refusa de jurés et il fit bien car le
lendemain à quoi songe dû à la forêt aux
bêtes libre out obéissons à l'on vient
on ne peut pas avancer seul qu'est ce
que tu dis alors et c'est encore cette
sale bête puisque c'est comme ça d'être
les mois je ne suis plus à votre service
marche qui marquera une autre fois
mais la décision du cerf été prise en
arrivant au chant les deux bêtes furent
des clés et des que les parents eurent
commencé à travailler cette fois ci je
parle et je pars pour toujours mais ce
n'est pas de me retenir tu perdrais
contre bon alors je pars aussi tu
m'attends parler de la vie des bois que
je rate de la colle être des crampons
partons sur la botte des pâtes pour que
les parents ne nous entendent ma tout
l'hérault plus on voit le long et aux
forces qui fait bon la liberté
maintenant entrons dans le bois tout est
encore plus beau que je l'imaginais
tiens dépêche toi un peu je n'avance pas
aussi facilement que toi si tu étais en
danger il faudrait bien tu cours je n'y
arriverai jamais j'espère que là tu as
de la place oui je vais pouvoir respirer
un peu ouf
qu'est ce qui m'arrive c'est que nous
sommes sur un marécage jeu toi pourquoi
non fons tue pas parce que je suis plus
léger que toi bon je vois que la forêt
ne me convient pas si j'arrive à sortir
de là je retournerai à la ferme
d'ailleurs je ne ferai que tu encombrer
un dieu donne à grands coups de langue
ou de petites de ma part si leurs
parents ne m'avait pas vaincu n'aurait
jamais eu le courage de les quitter lé
toit et toutes les belles de là bas vous
allez me manquer en apprenant la fuite
du cerf les parents regrettèrent les
coups de bâton et dû racheter un autre
buzz qui leur coûta le cuir et le poil
mais c'était bien fait quant au petit
elle ne voulurent pas croire que leur
ami était parti pour toujours
or quelques semaines après nous a
oubliés ils jouent avec les lapins et
les écureuils oubliée j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle vous apprend à mieux c'est oui
on va être là tué hier après midi
et pourtant j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai
pu pour entraîner la meute sur une
fausse piste
mais mes camarades se méfiait de moi
quand je suis arrivée près du cerf il
respirait encore et il m'a reconnu avec
ses dents il a cueilli une petite
marguerite et il me l'a donnée pour vous
elle est passée dans montpellier
prenez là
et maintenant je ne veux plus entendre
parler de chasse est-ce que vos parents
ont toujours envie d'un chien
[Musique]